Take for example,
one of our beautiful viewers, Gloria.
She is an amazing special education teacher
who went above and beyond
to connect with her students this year
while also taking care of herself and her family.
She is a rock star in the classroom
but when it comes to her closet,
I think she feels anything but.
She's here, its Gloria!
(audience clapping and cheering loudly)
Thank you so much for having me.
Thank you so much for coming here Gloria.
So it is true,
organization is always my last priority lists.
I worry about everybody else.
As a teacher, unfortunately we don't leave at three o'clock
at the end of the day.
There's lesson plans to write
and figuring out how to get these kids
to where we need to be.
And then add the pandemic on top of everything else.
And having three kids of my own,
it's really hard because when I go home,
I have hours and hours of homework with them.
So it's stressful.
It's really stressful.
Having a husband with a job lost
during this whole COVID time,
that's stressful too, you know?
So I feel like the weight of the world is on my shoulders
and when I go home at the end of the day,
sometimes organization is not first in my list.
But Drew if you called me
and told me you need something at your house,
like help with something,
I'd be the first one to help you.
But then when it comes to me organizing my closet,
I'm like rummaging through things in the morning
trying to find two shoes that match.
And like, I am the hot mess express.
I look put together
but I'm not.
(audience laughing loudly)
Well, we love your dedication to your students,
your family and just everything.
So we actually have a little message from your family.
Take a look.
Surprise mom!
(Gloria chuckles)
We got together
with the team at Drew
to design a bedroom for you,
fit for a queen.
We love you so much and you do so much for us
so now it's time for us to do something nice for you.
You're the best!
We all love you, mom.
Bye.
Oh, that's so sweet.
(audience clapping and cheering loudly)
Wow, how sweet is that.
(Gloria chuckles)
I mean, ah, it's just,
I just love that so much.
And I teamed up with a friend of mine
and a friend of the show,
a celebrity interior designer, Mikel Welch
and we together are transforming your bedroom
into a relaxing and organized
and just a beautiful retreat.
And I hope it's something that resonates with you
and works..
Thanks so much.
For your energy
and gives a little bit of all that avalanche
that you deserve.
So are you ready to see your new space?
Yes.
Okay, great.
All right guys, here we go!
(audience clapping and cheering loudly)
Oh my God!
Hey!
Hey hot mess of stress (chuckles).
Oh my God!
How are you?
It's beautiful.
Oh my God.
I'm super excited to show you your new room.
I wish I could give you a hug.
I know I can't, I'm a hugger.
But I know I can't.
This is so beautiful.
Hey Mikel.
It's so good to see you again.
Oh, it's wonderful to see you.
I told you we'd be seeing each other soon.
You did, you did!
Oh, I wasn't lying.
(Mikel chuckles)
Mikel..
Yes.
I'm really excited to learn from you
and how you approached this room and Gloria's closet.
Okay, so Gloria,
I think the biggest solution for you
was to add an oversize wardrobe
which we've done here.
Honey, we have storage and storage and more storage.
So you see here, we have hanging bar
so you can get all of your
longer hanging..
Amazing.
dresses in order.
And then check this out,
we've got all of these rollout bins.
So you know how you have like your T-shirts
sometimes you roll them up.
Like you can put jeans, T-shirts everything
and you look like a bling type of girl.
So I know..
Bling, bling, bling, yes.
You're into jewelry.
So we've even got you
jewelry pull outs.
That is amazing.
So now everything..
Oh two of them!
Wow!
Two of them!
This is a lot of bling.
I've got to control it all here.
So you've got all of your places for everything just to go.
Now here's the other thing,
I also saw you have a ton of shoes.
You're like Sarah Jessica Parker, right?
(Gloria chuckles)
Well,
I have a solution for that.
So check this out.
Wow, beautiful!
Now,
I know right now you can house every single shoe.
And then last but not least,
over here we gave you some double hang
so you just hang..
Amazing.
Lots of clothes.
You have lots and lots and lots of storage over here.
You can really get this at any Big-Box store per se.
And the thing I like about this particular unit
is you can kinda customize it.
And like here we did an L shape unit
based upon Gloria's, the size of her closet.
And then did you personalize the handles?
I did, I did!
(Drew claps loudly)
It looks good.
This was so brilliant.
Oh, I'm glad you like it.
She liked it.
Oh, I love it.
Now I've got you
some under the bed..
Oh yes, love it.
Storage bags
and these are great
because like Drew, you know,
like right now you wanna start taking those sweaters
and beginning to put them away.
Right, right.
So you can totally put all of your warm clothes here
and just like get rid of it.
And this goes right back up under the bed
and you're good to go.
And you know what else is my favorite piece?
And I have to give Drew complete credit for this.
So the other day..
What did I do Mikel?
Well, I'm gonna tell you.
So we were putting the design together
and I had just like a pretty ottoman
and Drew was like, no
like she needs to like have some function.
So Drew says she wanted a storage ottoman.
Love it, it's amazing!
So now,
you can have extra storage.
If your husband gets on your nerves you can..
Put him in there.
Put him in there too.
So you are covered.
Listen,
I'm gonna lock my green,
the padlock on the front
once it looks beautiful like nobody's coming in.
There you go.
I don't care where they go,
I just need a place to like quiet at all.
Oh, I think
you got that covered.
I'm gonna lock that door.
(Mikel chuckles)
This has a really nice surface area.
So you can actually sit on it and use it as a seat.
But this is brilliant.
Yes, yeah.
That's amazing, awesome.
So I know that you're a teacher
and I wanted to give you some dual type of storage as well.
So this right here, we see it's a beautiful desk
but it's more than just the desk.
This is also your bedside table.
Yep.
So let's think about,
you're sitting here, you're prepping your meeting notes
for tomorrow and you're in your bed.
Now you can just put your glass of water right here
with the coaster..
Amazing.
And you're totally done.
And look at this, we've even got a cute little picture
from your daughter.
I love that.
(both Gloria and Mikel laughing loudly)
Your daughter made that for you.
Its sweet.
And so this makes this area really special for you.
Beautiful, beautiful, thank you so much.
And I love that you color blocked the walls.
Amazing.
Oh my gosh!
That was like a quick like little DIY moment.
I was just like,
okay, what would Drew like?
And I'm like, I needed something simple and easy
and I feel like this is something
that you can knock out in a weekend
with just like a gallon of paint.
Mhm.
Like literally,
you're just painting the wall.
And I got some one inch strips of molding
from my local hardware store
and I just placed those right on the wall.
And I just raised the chair rail just a bit
and it instantly changes the room.
Amazing.
Instantly.
It's beautiful.
And Mikel you're..
It's so beautiful.
So amazing.
And Gloria, I really,
I hope that this sings to you
and brings you some peace and organization.
Absolutely, it's like a dream come true.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I'm glad that you liked it.
Thank you Mikel.
Thank you.
Always,
I cannot wait till our next project.
(all laughing loudly)
(upbeat music)